I have no choice but to start today with
the Brazen and immoral not just
willingness but desire to hurt Americans
from the newly in control of the House
of Representatives Republican party
because they believe it will help them
in 2024. yesterday I told you about a
post that the failed former president
Donald Trump made to his social media
platform truth social truth essential
and to review that post let's just put
it up on the screen where Donald Trump
said in all capital letters quote
Republicans can get almost everything
back that the old broken Crow Mitch
McConnell and the real leader
china-centric Coco Chao stupidly gave up
to the Democrats over the last two years
by simply playing tough in the upcoming
debt ceiling negotiations with the right
negotiators like all of those involved
the other night on both sides for
speaker it will be a beautiful and
joyous thing for the people of our
country to watch make America great
again now you sometimes have to read
between the lines when Trump speaks
because it does it's not even clear he
knows what he's saying in this case he
does know what he's saying he is saying
shut down the government over the debt
ceiling damage the country which will
then show people how much they want
Republicans in power and they will vote
for us in 2024. now it was not just
Donald Trump who became willing to say
this over the last 24 hours we have
countless more examples now and I'm
going to look at a couple first and
foremost last night
Sean Hannity Fox News propagand this
hosted some kind of a sort of town hall
type event with the new Speaker of the
House Kevin McCarthy and here is Sean
Hannity suggesting to Kevin McCarthy
shut down the government
shut down the government when it comes
down to the debt ceiling debate take a
listen by the way what they did in the
Senate I believe as a conservative that
was a disgrace yeah I think and they
knew you were coming into power and they
knew they could why wouldn't they just
wait if they waited then we'd have a
stronger hand exactly we wouldn't be
increasing it and they increased the
Baseline where it just adds so much more
to our children let's talk about a
moment maybe it comes sooner maybe it
comes later on the debts ceiling and you
know how the argument will unfold it'll
be Republicans are shutting down
government I've been around this game
too long government never shuts down
essential services will exist Grandma
Mom and Dad they're going to get their
social security check Medicare is not
going to be shut down the military is
not going to be shut down now there
might be people that get furloughed ah
but odds are pretty high that when they
get their free vacation they they will
get back pay
but that will be the argument yeah so
Hannity likes the idea here of the
government shutdown now the question
will be it'll become a game of chicken
and that is Republicans are shutting
down the government and they're not
willing to raise the debt ceiling and
you're going to say what well listen it
doesn't have to come to that I've
already spoken to the president let's
sit down now yeah so Hannity likes the
idea and he says they'll say it's bad
for the country when the government when
the government is shut down but it's not
really that bad for the country now I
disagree with that and I'm going to
explain that to you in a moment here's
another example new Republican
congresswoman Anna Paulina Luna she says
she's also willing to support a shutdown
of the government oh I just stand by
because it's going to be a wild week
well you know some of your moderate
members within the Republican party as
I'm sure you know say that's a dangerous
thing because it sets up almost a
guaranteed government shutdown
um and that because spending has been
tied to renegotiating the debt limit or
extending it it's inevitable do you
think it's inevitable that we'll be
looking at a shutdown because of some of
these measures that the speaker agreed
to
um I hope it doesn't get to that but I'm
willing to support one and I do think
that the speaker made the correct
decision in ensuring that we do cut
again some of this pork Runway inflation
and spending and so she's willing to
support a government shutdown now of
course there's two sides to this the
first side of it is that for many of
these Republicans the government being
shut down is a feature not a bug in the
sense that as I've told you many times
before many of these right Wingers want
government doing as little as possible
and so for them when they say oh the
government shut down that's great as
much as we can take off of the list of
things that government is doing that's a
good thing now often they can't come out
and publicly say that but privately many
of them love government shutdown because
they don't want the government doing
stuff they still want their paychecks by
the way but they don't want government
doing stuff but it is not true
that when the government is shut down
over the debt ceiling it doesn't impact
anything now in a sense yes in the
immediate people continue to get Social
Security checks but when the government
shuts down essential government services
stop being funded that does include
Social Security and Medicare now in the
immediate people still get their checks
but it is not indefinitely true and so
the idea that it has no impact is of
course a lie it can also lead to a
Slowdown in the economy when the
government shuts down government
contracts government purchases are put
on hold government employees are
furloughed sometimes they get back pay
sometimes they don't it can cause job
losses and financial difficulties for
the government workers but also for the
private sector businesses that rely on
government spending now again some of
these Republicans love that some of
these Republicans think we the
government shouldn't do deals with
private businesses the government
shouldn't be to be spending the
government shouldn't be doing the
government should be shut down that's
their default that's very extreme
we're talking about those in the middle
who say well I want the government open
in principle but it's not that bad if
it's shut down it really can be very
very bad it raises the risk of a debt
default which can have more than dire
consequences uh a default can lead to an
increase in interest rates and that
makes it more expensive for the
government to borrow money for
individuals and businesses to borrow
money as a result of that all of these
things when they say there's no negative
impact what I think they're saying is if
we contrive this deliberately but it
only lasts a little while we will reopen
after we've made our political point
before things get too bad but that's an
extraordinarily cynical approach to how
you do politics and
um the truth is that a government
shutdown is bad for the American people
in all sorts of different ways it's
irresponsible it's Reckless and they are
willing to do it they don't have
principles or at least the principles
they have are very different than the
ones they publicly State a real Prince
principle for the 2023 Republican party
or House Republicans we could say
is let's do whatever we think is best
for us politically over the next couple
of years that's a real principle the
principles they'll state are were for
small government conservatism and
freedom and liberty and the Constitution
and supporting law enforcement and
every single one of those we've seen
abandoned when they're no longer
convenient the real principle that they
pledge allegiance to on in an unwavering
fashion is one they won't say out loud
we will do whatever it takes to try to
make Democrats look bad
and to try to help ourselves for our own
re-elections and whatever the next
election cycle is they're making it very
clear they're saying it openly and by
the way they're also now talking about
diversity while in a room full of white
people emblematic of what the Republican
party is I want to talk about that next
Republicans are now bragging
about diversity
quite literally in a room full of white
people mostly white men this you you
just have to see it and I want to talk
about diversity in sort of a more
serious way and actually take the
question of diversity more seriously
Republicans have started to repeat lines
like this is one of the most diverse
Republican classes we've ever had
we have more women we have more this
that the other thing they thought they
had more Jewish people because they were
including George Santos and that turns
out that that was a lie and during the
event that they did yesterday with Fox
News propagandist Sean Hannity they
talked about this issue of diversity a
couple of times I'm going to play a
couple of clips for you here is Sean
Hannity saying he loves seeing more
diversity in the Republican party you
know uh congresswoman I know I've known
you a long time
um one of the things I'd like to see and
I'm seeing yeah is more diversity in the
Republican party to me the Democratic
party is the party of coastal
okay I think he uh Elites Coastal Elites
yes and then Elise stefanic actually
talks about it and she does some of the
types of bragging we've heard for the
last few weeks from Republicans take a
look around at these wonderful members
this is the most diverse class of
Republicans ever elected in the history
of the United States Congress we have
more women than were ever elected before
more Hispanic members ever elected
before now as you see the camera panning
it's basically all white men in the room
for this very special Republican event I
guess I see three women in the
background someone pointed out that
there's one guy that maybe is Hispanic
but okay you get the point more
African-American members in modern
history this shows that our party is
growing and I will tell you the America
First agenda is a growing big tent
agenda we've never done better than we
do today among Hispanic voters and
president Trump and House Republicans
were a huge part of doing that okay so
there's a few things that we have to
understand first of all when the initial
when they talk about we're doing better
than ever with a lot of these groups
when you start with such disastrous
numbers you really only have up as the
direction that you can go so I wouldn't
read too much into that but what these
Republicans very much expose is that for
them this issue of diversity is checking
a box it's perfunctory it's contrived
it's just something that they can say so
that they can argue hey we also have
different types of people here like the
Democrats do it's not organic it doesn't
stem from policy it comes from who can
we fleece because the entire movement is
a scam we exposed that two weeks ago you
can check out the segment modern modern
conservatism is a scam
but the reality is that these aren't
just boxes that you check
the makeup
of political constituencies is a direct
reflection of the policies or the
perceived policies of those groups and
that's why this can very quickly become
a fraught debate first of all it's not
about we need the exact makeup in our
elected officials of the population at
large you can never really achieve that
because you can always say hey you know
what uh there's 50 the population is
50.3 percent women
so we should have 50.3 women in the
House of Representatives okay all right
well you could probably do that okay
here's the racial demographics of the
country they should be exactly
represented in the House of
Representatives okay maybe you could do
that all right here's the percentage of
the country that is immigrants that
should be exactly represented also the
percentage of people with a physical
disability should be rep sexual oriented
it's extraordinarily difficult to have a
perfect mirroring in our elected
officials of every demographic alignment
in the general population that's not
what this is about I don't believe
that's what the left is actually talking
about the important thing to know
is that voter demographics
that support political groups vary based
on a lot of different factors it can
depend on the candidates that are that
are running and how they appeal to
different groups of people it could
depend on what the most important issues
are when National Security and the
economy maybe are the issues being
emphasized you're going to see a
different demographic alignment than if
the issues are say abortion and
education just for for picking certain
ones but what we see is that
overwhelmingly there is very little
diversity in the Republican party now I
know Trump does these events and he puts
blacks for Trump on the stage behind him
and it's all very uh uh uh stage managed
for lack of a better term but roughly
speaking somewhere between 89 and 93 of
black voters vote for Democrats 93
percent voted for Joe Biden based on
exit polls 78 percent of LGBT voters
voted for Biden 71 percent of Jewish
Americans identify as or lean towards
Democratic candidates 66 percent of
Hispanic or Latino voters voted for
Biden 66 of Asian American voters voted
for Biden 62 percent of naturalized
citizens uh people like me voted for Joe
Biden 60 of those 18 to 29 voted for Joe
Biden 59 of disabled voters voted for
Joe Biden 55 percent of women okay
you're getting closer and closer to 50
50. diversity isn't something you do to
get it on record but you go hey we got
some Jewish folks like George Santos oh
he's not Jewish all right cross him off
the list but we've still got more Latino
voters than we've had before it's a
reflection of policy it's a reflection
of policy the way the Republican party
goes about it is let's just see if we
can find people who check certain boxes
and convince them to vote for us rather
than let's develop a policy platform
that will naturally attract different
groups of Voters they're sort of going
like top down rather than building from
the bottom up and it's not clear whether
that will work as a long-term political
strategy their numbers have improved
slightly over the last couple of
election Cycles with some of these
groups but with others they continue to
be a disaster the way the Republican
Party sees this issue is just like a
product what kind of a product can we
build by adding people who check
different demographic boxes and as a
result they're really not doing well
with just about any of these groups the
the irony of course is as the room as
the camera pans it's all white people
and mostly white men which is really in
contrast to the words about diversity
that are coming out of their mouths you
know the last time that Republicans
controlled the house was 2011 to 2019.
and I think it's important to remind
ourselves the things that the House of
Representatives focused on and did
during the time that Republicans last
controlled the house because yesterday I
did the segment for you about things are
very quickly getting very stupid in the
house now that Republicans control the
House of Representatives and many of you
wrote to me and I could tell that there
was sort of a lack of awareness of what
things were like during that period that
Republicans previously controlled the
house there was a total lack of doing
anything helpful to the American people
during that period of time and forget
about lack of helpful
think about the damage that was actually
done by Republicans controlling the
house for that period of time
Republicans in the house when they
controlled it voted roughly 50 times to
repeal the Affordable Care Act now you
could depending on how you want to slice
and dice it in the ways in which they
did it the number might be higher than
50 or lower roughly 50 times in some way
shape or form Republicans voted to
repeal the Affordable Care Act that was
one where way that they spent resources
when they last controlled the house had
they succeeded it would have resulted in
millions of people losing health care
including people with pre-existing
conditions now thankfully the repeal
effort failed but the fact that
Republicans were willing to strip people
of their health care should be
concerning to all of us you might
remember also at the beginning of Donald
Trump's term in 2017 they proposed that
other health care plan which would have
led to tens of millions of Americans
losing Health Care coverage thankfully
that didn't become law but that was a
priority for a formerly
republican-controlled House Republicans
when they last controlled the house
systematically rolled back environmental
regulations they withdrew from the Paris
climate agreement they quite literally
took actions that worsened the prospects
for Homo sapiens on planet Earth they
gutted the epa's budget
making it harder for the EPA to protect
air to protect water but they were in
control these are the things they did
they were a disaster on immigration
including separation of families at the
border caging of children although they
could have moved forward on doing
something more permanent with DACA they
didn't even though they controlled the
house and they could have taken some of
the credit and then of course on taxes
we can't forget the attempted tax bills
Republicans tried to pass but failed to
pass and also what they did pass
including in 2017 under Donald Trump
exploding the deficit large portion of
the benefits going to the top one
percent that's the record of Republicans
last time they controlled the house and
they're sometimes enlightened centrists
as I call them who love to say well
divided government is good it's good
when one party controls the Senate and
the other the house so that nobody gets
too much power it's it's meaningless
pablum it's just something people say to
sound like they are thinking critically
and moderate and whatever else when
Republicans get control of a legislative
body they do horrible things now when
Democrats control have control they
often fail to accomplish things as well
but there's really no comparison here
and so when we think back to that period
of time it really serves as a disturbing
preview of what we're up against over
the next two years
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
I'm going to admit to you I'm almost a
little bit starting to think about maybe
feeling kind of bad for the failed
former president Donald Trump
look at the people that are into
interviewing him lately look at the
sorts of appearances he's doing where he
can't even be bothered to put a camera
in front of his face he's quite
literally just phoning it in and even
with the friendliest interviewers just
making a complete and total fool of
himself low energy interviews where
Trump just tells a lot of the same lies
he's told for a while but you can tell
even his heart's not even really in the
lies and the themes are delusion and the
rewriting of History confusion in many
cases as well as weaponized narcissism
Trump appeared yesterday calling in of
course on real America's voice and it's
just bizarre that he's still trying to
get away with these same tired lies the
host is completely friendly and Trump
still can't figure out a way to seem
like a normal person here is Trump
weighing in on the investigation into
him Trump says they should drop the
investigation into what I did with all
those classified documents because
because of the 12 documents that were
left behind by Joe Biden somewhere that
his lawyers immediately found and
contacted the presidential the Nara
National Archives listen to this and you
of course have been facing this
situation with the special prosecutor
how does this change the equation with
what you've been doing with the justice
department to get this map and remember
the question is how does the Biden thing
change your situation the answer is not
at all
well I think it totally changes it I
mean he's again he's under this federal
act that's very tough and I'm gonna I I
was perfect under the presidential
records act we were negotiating with
Nara now you know Nara is a far left
group of people that's not true I don't
know if you know or if you've ever heard
they've red flagged essentially red flag
the Constitution of the United States
they said it's a dangerous document this
is what we're dealing with these are
people that uh you know look they have
some real difficulties so listen first
of all if you are accused of murder and
then someone else gets accused of murder
they don't stop investigating you they
investigate both of you and maybe of the
two people accused of murder one person
did the thing and the other didn't the
fact that Trump is being investigated
for taking at his Direction tons of
documents down to Mar-A-Lago
trying to avoid returning them hiding
them moving them on and on and on the
fact that Trump is accused of that
has no connection whatsoever to the fact
that a few documents were found by
Biden's lawyers they immediately called
the National Archives and said we've got
to get these back to you investigate
Biden for that I'm fine with that as
I've said yesterday but number one it
has no connection to anything that Trump
is accused of doing and number two
look at the differences in how they
handled it as we talked about yesterday
Trump then weighing in on the new
speaker
and Trump I guess tries to make the case
that he deserves the credit for Kevin
McCarthy being speaker I came down to
crunch time you know you had 20 people
that were pretty hard line and they
happened to be very good friends of mine
almost all of them I would say all of
them right and uh I would make them
calls I mean because I I didn't like
what was happening John it it was
starting to look a little bit chaotic it
was starting to look a little bit not
good you think right and what happened
is I started calling them and I started
getting people to agree with me and
coming on board right and as you know
Matt Gates is a very good guy and he's
you know he's a strong guy and I called
him big strong guy and he was crying
when I spoke to him at the end I mean it
was just about
over where they were going to leave and
I think that if they left think of it if
they left and you had two and a half
three days in between I don't know that
anything would have ever you might have
ended up with a Democrat to be honest
with you Trump wants us to believe that
were it not for him not only would
McCarthy not be speaker maybe Hakeem
Jeffries would be the speaker I know
that this thing ever would have gotten
done your moderates would have left
other people it would have been a
disaster right and that's when Matt ran
up to the front of the room and he said
I'm changing my vote I'm changing my
vote and he's a great guy yeah now
understand that after Trump issued a not
quite full-throated endorsement of Kevin
McCarthy for house Speaker it took like
12 more rounds of voting before McCarthy
ultimately became the speaker and if we
learned anything from the speaker vote
it's not how much power Trump still has
it's how diminished his power actually
is Trump then of course weighed in on
one of his favorite topics covid and
favorite insofar as he loves to claim he
did great on handling kovid when he was
president
he did not do great doing it and then we
got hit with covet and we had to help
the people with covet you know we would
have done that this country would have I
don't think it would have existed you
know it was uh we did a great job with
covet I've always felt that you know
people give me a lot of credit on
foreign policy on the economy and things
no they don't but they they don't like
doing it on covet I think I did among
the best jobs on covid because all of a
sudden something came in that nobody had
any idea what it was right we knew it
was killing a lot of people and you know
I closed it to China so now covet was
serious in retrospect remember 15 cases
will soon be zero don't be afraid of it
it's fine now it's oh it was terrible
and I really handled it well a lot of
people didn't want me to do that almost
nobody wanted that was that saved a lot
of lives but you know uh the covet thing
obviously we had to go guns are blazing
with uh with the money and we had no
choice otherwise you know we had a
remember 15 cases will soon be zero
um what about injecting bleach uh don't
don't don't be afraid of it the
shutdowns are worse than the disease on
and on and on and and the the truth is
the proof is in the outcome world
leaders who handled covet well were all
easily easily re-elected and there is no
doubt that Trump would have been
re-elected if he from the beginning had
said this is really serious
and we're going to do the best job by
being the most aggressive here let's all
wear our masks we're going to offer you
Maga masks that you can buy let's all do
all these things instead they went after
an 80 year old doctor that's that's the
the approach that they ended up taking
okay last thing Trump wants Hannity to
write so that Hannity can get the
Pulitzer and I guess bring back some
Prestige to an award Trump believes is
no longer prestigious yeah
to get the Pulitzer Prize for Russia
Russia Russia reporting and you know the
prize reads to the effect on your great
and Brilliant reporting in Russia well
they got it wrong it was the exact
opposite you should get the Pulitzer
Prize yeah Sean Hannity should start
writing a little bit and get the
bulletship hey you guys eyes and Sarah
yes there was a group of people that got
it right right in the beginning and yeah
and you know I'm suing Pulitzer now
because I'm saying you got to take the
post I'm suing vulitzer now you know
um completely deranged and delusional
and I mean listen how about just do the
George Santos claim that you got the
Pulitzer Prize and the Nobel Peace Prize
and whatever else a purple heart and you
lived in the belly of a whale just claim
that you did this stuff but very very
strange Trump deflated Trump confused
Trump disoriented but as narcissistic as
ever even in his rewriting of History
maybe at some point soon he'll show his
face in one of these interviews that
would be an interesting thing to see but
for a guy who criticized Joe Biden for
campaigning from his basement Trump's
barely left his house since he announced
he was running in 2024 back in November
very strange stuff Donald Trump's former
CFO is going to jail we're talking about
Alan weisselberg he has indeed been
sentenced and this is starting to get
closer and closer and closer to the
Inner Circle of the Trump World CNBC
reports former Trump organization CFO
Alan weisselberg sent to jail for five
months in the tax fraud case former
Trump organization Chief Financial
Officer Alan weisselberg was sent into
five months in jail after pleading
guilty to multiple tax crimes related to
former president Trump's businesses
weisselberg was expected to begin
serving as jail term in New York City's
notorious Rikers Island facility
following a sentencing hearing
weisselberg and several of Trump's
business entities were charged in what
prosecutors called a systematic scheme
to defraud state and federal tax
authorities spanning more than 15 years
the article goes on to say that the 75
year old was handcuffed and let out of a
Manhattan courtroom shortly after 2 30
Eastern with a very brief sentencing
hearing before the state judge Juan
Merchant he will be immediately
transported to Rikers Island now some of
you are saying David sir I'm crying
because weisselberg isn't being shipped
up to one of those swankier Federal
facilities my understanding is that
because his sentence is shorter I
believe under a year although fact check
me on that he goes to jail rather than
prison and based on the location it's
Rikers which is not exactly a place you
want to spend too too much time if you
can avoid it now of course the questions
continue to be Georgia grand jury is
done
and we will soon know whether Trump is
getting indicted there January 6th
committee is done that was in the last
Congress now it's Republicans control
the house January 6 committees done
January 6 Committee of the previous
Congress made a criminal referral of
trump and others to the Department of
Justice we are waiting there to see
whether Merrick Garland will as some
like to say have the testicular
fortitude to charge Donald Trump and
then third we've got things happening in
New York and those relate to Trump's
business in in great part and other
things and there remains a sort of
general question mark as to whether
there may be charges there so we may end
up with no charges against Trump we may
end up with charges from one of these
areas New York Georgia federal charges
could be two and it could be three
if it's three and I don't think that
that's particularly likely what does it
do for Trump's campaign and is Trump
actually looking to bail on the campaign
anyway given how disastrously it's going
questions we will hopefully soon answer
all of the clips I've played here you
can find on our Instagram at
davidpackman show and please please
please make sure
that you are subscribed to the YouTube
channel at youtube.com the davidpackman
show you know there's this thing called
the bystander effect people walk by
someone's being brutally beaten on the
street no one calls the police because
they assume someone else is going to
call real story from history don't allow
the bystander effect of someone else
will subscribe and help them get to 2
million subscribers on YouTube don't
fall for that be the person it costs
nothing it's just a click and you get us
one step closer to an incredible
Milestone two million YouTube
subscribers
if you value what we do at the David
Pacman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so many of
you wrote to me about anti-vaccine
Diamond of diamond and silk Fame dying
of covid and everything we know right
now does suggest she did die of covid
although there are still remaining
questions over this diamond and silk
were this Duo of trump supporters who
became sort of well known because Trump
promoted them and would sometimes invite
them on stage they were vehemently
anti-vaccine scene they also
were confused about a lot of different
issues including the price of mangoes as
many of you know but that's a completely
different story uh the belief right now
is indeed that the death was the result
of covid they were very aggressively
anti-vaccine which we will talk about AP
reports Diamond of the pro-trump duo
diamond and silk dead at 51. Lynette
Hardaway uh an Ardent supporter of
President Donald Trump and half of the
duo diamond and silk has died
Hardaway known by the moniker Diamond
carved out a unique role I'll say as a
black woman who loudly backed Trump her
promotion of coveted falsities
eventually got her dropped from Fox News
but she landed on another right wing
cable platform the pairs verify Twitter
account asked people to quote please
pray for diamond in a November tweet but
did not elaborate on the circumstances
Newsweek reports was Lynette hardaway's
cause of death covid what we know what
we don't
um on Monday evening the Duo's Twitter
page confirmed Hardaway had died but
asked for privacy and did get gave no
information on the manner of death
um the article goes on to say some
social media users claimed Hardaway died
from covid but it has not been confirmed
by the family or her group page many of
these claims are made on the basis of a
report from the website blavity which
now appears to be unavailable Daily
Beast reporter will summer highlighted
the Tweet I'm seeing claims that diamond
of diamond and silk a coveted vaccine
hater died of covid and was hospitalized
for it but the truth is her cause of
death isn't clear yet and the November
claims that she had coveted came from a
blavaty article that appears to have
been deleted
um Maga supporter Diamond of diamond and
silk has been hospitalized due to covid
was reported in November but that is
based on that underlying report which
now is unclear as to its truth
what we do know is that Donald Trump put
out a statement about the death of
diamond saying quote really bad news for
republicans and frankly all Americans
are beautiful Diamond of diamond and
silk has just passed away at her home in
the state she loved so much North
Carolina
silk was wither all the way and at her
passing there was no better team
anywhere or at any time Diamond's death
was totally unexpected probably her big
and Precious Heart just plain gave out
rest in peace our magnificent Diamond
you will greatly you will be greatly
missed
um Trump's speculating about the cause
of death as well and as a reminder here
was their view about coveted vaccines
yes we don't need to look at the
community right but what we don't need
to happen is what happened with Africa
when Bill Gates in them took that
vaccine to Africa trying to vaccinate
they felt like stuff can start right
there in certain parts of of Africa
that's what we don't need to you're not
gonna make black people not the guinea
pig
no uh yo yo project right not black yes
today Billy yes the sergeant the Surgeon
General was talking to as a matter of
fact he was trending today listen I I
tell us what we need to know yeah but I
always look at the underbelly of what's
going on that's not the intuition in me
yeah that's my intuitive yeah quad
counterpart yes what are you about to do
here right because what you're not gonna
do you're not gonna start vaccinating
blackfo right and we have to have a
vaccination card just to go to work so
you're not gonna do that and what it
does is it'll start with us first right
all right anyway I think you get the
point so listen
unclear if she died of covet uh today's
voicemail is related to the death of
diamond I take no pleasure in anyone's
death vaccinated or unvaccinated I never
have a Donald Trump Jr and others claim
people on the left want right Wingers to
die of covid or to die unvaccinated or
vaccinated or whatever that's absolutely
insane there is absolutely no evidence
whatsoever that I take pleasure or hope
for the death of any of these folks
whether it be Herman Cain or whoever
else if indeed it was a death from kovid
and she was unvaccinated that is a
tragedy it's a tragedy of weaponized
disinformation uh although uh we we know
that against the new variants the
vaccine does not prevent transmission or
infection it does reduce the odds that
you die and it has likely saved tens of
millions of people globally
um and whatever the circumstances are of
this death although I found her
political views disgusting and
deplorable
um and um contradictory to everything I
stand for
uh I do not wish harm on anybody and we
will I believe at some point find out
the truth about the death of diamond I
want to play a video for you of an
attendee at a turning point USA event
where a woman blames Donald Trump for
millions of vaccine deaths what what how
what is she talking about she says I'm a
DeSantis gal because Trump led to
millions of vaccine deaths listen to
this Trump or DeSantis right
DeSantis all day why well because I
don't like vaccine salesmen and uh
millions of people are being killed all
across the world and I blame Donald
Trump for that right Trump helped
develop the vaccines she believes anyway
um and therefore Trump is responsible
for the millions of vaccine deaths
around the world you know I think at
this point in January of 2023
if you still believe the coveted
vaccines have killed millions of people
I doubt I can say anything to bring you
back to reality but this has been
floating around for a long time there's
just no evidence that people are dying
from the covid vaccine it's important to
understand that when these folks talk
about the vayers system vaccine adverse
event Reporting System vayers anybody
can submit anything they want to the
vayer system it's not a definitive
source of information on vaccine safety
the submissions to vayers include
anything that happens after vaccination
whether it's related to the vaccine or
not you get a heart attack and die 10
months after getting vaccinated it can
end up in theirs and people like this
woman will say that's a vaccine death
theirs is a passive surveillance system
it relies on people like you or me or a
health care professional to voluntarily
report events that take place it doesn't
capture all Adverse Events it doesn't
link adverse event events to the vaccine
it doesn't do any of those things I even
on a live stream filled out such a
report I didn't hit submit because I
don't want to be part of the fraud but
anybody can just go in and say got the
vaccine and died uh it's not use useful
in figuring out whether people are dying
from the vaccine and when we ask the
question do we have evidence that people
are dying from the coveted vaccine the
answer is no
um you have a combination of lies and
then just correlation that is not
causation in any way car accident nine
months after the vaccine shows up in
vayers what the is that representative
of the spirit of what we're trying to
track it is not
um so unfortunately this stuff is still
around it's continuing to circulate I
don't know that I can single-handedly
shut down the disinformation but the
interesting thing with this particular
woman is DeSantis also said go and get
vaccinated he later backed off and said
well no mandates and not these people in
that and consider that the other thing
but DeSantis was also out there saying
people should get vaccinated I don't
think I can change her I don't think I
can change any of these people but at
some point if we can it's good to
introduce a little bit of reality to
some of these discussions
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
I want to revisit with you taxation is
theft it's the little brother to
taxation is slavery that we sometimes
hear from Republicans and right-wingers
a new congresswoman a republican of
course Anna Paulina Luna pulled out
taxation is theft yesterday when being
interviewed on Fox Business by Neil
Cavuto let's listen and then discuss the
endless bottomless absurdity of this
silly claim that some Republicans like
to make I'm not going to say that I want
to cut defense spending but I will say
that I think it's important that we are
looking to make sure that we are getting
the best deal especially on some of the
stuff that we're spending money on so I
think that we need to have those
discussions but more or less what I've
heard in some of these negotiations is
we're talking about programs that aren't
going to the Necessities that we the
American people need I.E protections I'm
talking about some of these woke
ideology these funded programs and for
example these uh these salaries for
these additional all weaponized 87 000
IRS agents which you saw we tried to
pass yet the Senate and even the Biden
White House is pushing back on sir I say
taxation is theft and I don't want any
more IRS agents than you probably do
so wait
I I'm going to restrict this segment to
taxation it's theft because it's it's
interesting okay so first of all Anna
Paulina Luna's salary
um is paid by taxes so if you really
believe taxation is theft then you
should be refusing your salary you
should reject such an ill-gotten and
stolen salary if you actually believe
that taxes are theft because you're
being paid with stolen money sort of
makes you an accessory to the theft
that's number one she's not rejecting
her salary that I'm aware of but let's
talk about taxation is theft
taxations theft every once in a while
rears its ugly head usually among
libertarian circles but sometimes among
reactionary Maga as well
taxation is not theft in a number of
different ways first of all
nobody is forcing you to pay taxes in
the sense that you have the option to
work or not to work don't want to pay
taxes don't work oh but then how would I
fund my life well you have a choice
secondly if you believe that the
taxation system in the United States is
theft you can try to go to a different
country that might have a different
system what you might find is that the
countries in which you can get away with
paying no taxes aren't places you
probably want to live now you might say
well David Ever every country has taxes
so well your if your argument is the
American government is stealing through
taxes you're free to try to go somewhere
else if the immigration law will allow
you and if the tax law is more favorable
to you number three you have decided to
be here in the sense that you either
immigrated here knowing that there are
taxes in the United States or your
parents immigrated here and then birthed
you
or your parents were born here and chose
not to leave and birthed you here into
this system where there is taxes so you
do have a recourse your parents had
recourse there are options here and then
number four you can also Lobby to get
elected officials who agree that
taxation is theft and if they get
elected they can try to eliminate taxes
so it's not theft and it's not slavery
now the bigger picture of course is
there is no way to have a civilized
society without taxes
anthropological research
and other sociological research tells us
that one usually they talk about 150
it's called the Dunbar number when you
get to 150 people organizing 150 people
you need some centralization and some
decisions that are made thinking of the
group as a collective if you don't you
have untenable situations that would
prevent Homo sapiens from ever advancing
to the point at which we are now ideas
of every road can be private and you
know you build a road and then you just
charge people to go on it and every road
is private or police is private and fire
is pride these things these things quite
literally do not work once you get
Beyond groups of 150 people
and so these folks are living in a
complete and total fantasy world usually
you don't hear straight up taxation it's
theft from elected officials in the
House of Representatives you hear it
more from activists you hear it more
from anti-tax groups or libertarian
groups but to straight up hear taxation
is theft from someone in a position of
power like this really shows us the
degree of radicalization in the current
Republican Congress and it is very very
scary as I've been telling you all week
Marjorie Taylor green Republican
congresswoman now wants to be taken
seriously and unfortunately it's looking
increasingly like corporate media is
going to help her there's a really good
article in salon by Amanda Marcotte
which makes a lot of the points that
we've been making on the show this week
about Marjorie Taylor green and Amanda
writes quote Marjorie Taylor green wants
to be a mainstream Republican now sadly
the media will let it happen green is
walking the path lay made by the Tea
Party in which today's extremists become
tomorrow's new GOP normal this is a
really good article
and it points out a few different things
one of them is that there's no real
daylight between the two factions in in
other words the two factions we're
talking about are the pro Kevin McCarthy
pro-trump people and the anti-kevin
McCarthy pro-trump people remember as I
told you yesterday and the day before
you used to have Pro and anti-trump
Republicans
the anti-trump Republicans are still
there but now the pro-trump Republicans
have divided into two the ones that
wanted Kevin McCarthy to be speaker and
the ones that did not Amanda Marcotte
writes in this article that there is a
very good chance that corporate media is
going to allow Marjorie Taylor green to
Rebrand herself in this way that she is
trying to do it's extraordinarily
important that we not be fooled by this
Redemption tour of sorts that Marjorie
Taylor green now is on her perspective
is now that Kevin McCarthy is Speaker I
voted for the speaker Republicans are in
power I can either go the way of being
kind of one of these agitators like
Lauren bobert who she's very much in a
war with at this point in time or I can
be cozy with power
I can get back on committees and that's
very appealing to Marjorie Taylor green
she is clearly desperate for power and
part of this may even be starting to
think about continuing to Lobby to be
Donald Trump's vice presidential running
mate the other thing and this is not
about oh everyone's a fascist that's not
what I'm saying but when we think about
authoritarianism and fascist wannabes
and dictator wannabes fascists will
often do these rewriting of their own
history realignments these sort of
redemption tours if you allow them to do
it they will sort of mention some of my
past views were either mistakes or Jokes
which I regret Marjorie Taylor green did
that on Sunday where she said I got
sucked into some stuff on the internet
like it happens to everybody
and if you allow them they will rewrite
their own history Marjorie Taylor green
is desperate for power she's desperate
for credibility and recognition after
being a joke removed from committees and
essentially a laughing stock for two
years and she's probably angling for
some position of higher power it could
be within Congress it could be as Donald
Trump's running mate she wants to go
from Jewish space lasers to I'm normal I
fell for some stuff but please forgive
me now I'm really a mainstream
Republican just like Mitt Romney or
something like that corporate media
should not allow her to get away with
that and I have been careful when we
talk about George W bush and I say
listen if you put up a video of George W
bush and you put up a video of trump
obviously George W bush seems normal
compared to Trump but let's not allow
his reputation to be rehabilitated when
he did horrible things as president and
the media corporate media should not
allow Marjorie Taylor green to get away
with what she is very obviously trying
to do like Amanda Marcotte writes I'm
worried they will let her get away with
it but let's hope it doesn't happen one
other note on Marjorie Taylor green Mike
pillow
his real name is Mike Lindell he's the
CEO and founder of MyPillow Mike pillow
seems to be turning on Marjorie Taylor
green and this is the continued Rift
within the pro-trump wing of the
Republican party and pillow is not happy
with Marjorie Taylor green over her vote
for Kevin McCarthy and says she was
probably bribed with some kind of
promise for something take a listen to
this and you just think of this I want
you to think of this look when Matt
Gates put this out okay and what seven
was it the seventh or eighth vote now
think of this if you did it right out of
the gate you got to think of this as
marketing guys you know if you did it
right of the gate it's not going to fly
you I think right now it's happening
just the way it's gonna unfold here
where does this end it can only end with
McCarthy giving in it's not going to be
the other way and I'm telling you that I
know these guys uh if if they if they
have made promises to the Grassroots
they made promises to the people Matt
Gates is not going to make you break his
promise and neither I'm very surprised
that the one I won't name her name but
it's Marjorie Taylor green for promise
oh he let it slip out yeah the media can
say Mike Lindell bashes Marjorie Taylor
green
yeah
that she uh I mean it's her choice but
obviously she was promised something
yeah so listen people get promised stuff
all the time pillow is not wrong that
there's all sorts of horse trading and
promises and and that negotiation a
hundred percent that's the case the
message here though is when you've lost
Mike pillow but you are pro-trump that
is a serious Rift and of course the hope
is that this degrades and and destroys
the Republican party from within the
most important aspect to this that I
think it's important to refresh is that
at no point were these 20 Republicans or
the others were none of them at any
point were primarily concerned with what
is best for the American people they
were concerned with publicity they were
concerned with attention some of them
were probably concerned with staying in
Trump's good graces they were concerned
with all sorts of different things what
can I negotiate for myself how can I
seize power for myself what was not on
the list is what is best for the
American people that was not even a
consideration they turn on each other
they turn back their friends their
enemies you look at Dan Crenshaw you
look at Matt gates are they with Trump
are they not they disagree here they
agree there whatever
but never does it enter into the cons
into the calculus
what is best for the American people
here and the proof continues to be
presented in the reality that after they
finally agreed on a speaker after 15
votes and Kevin McCarthy took the gavel
and the whole thing
the first thing they went to was
repealing the funding bill for the IRS
which by the way they don't understand
they're confused about and also has zero
chance of even becoming a reality
because the Senate's not going to repeal
it and if they tried to Joe Biden would
veto it it's going nowhere it's just a
waste of time
the idea of hey what did the American
people need
what might be useful to the American
people why don't we look at health care
and getting people Health Care why don't
we look at education why don't we look
at climate why don't we look at energy
why don't we look at all these different
no it's just what about repealing the
IRS thing which we don't even understand
they do not care about the American
people and much like you know we had
these viral interviews and Luke Beasley
would do some for us at Trump events he
would ask people what do you like the
most about what Trump did
and the answers were either something
Trump didn't actually do or something
Trump did that has absolutely no impact
on their lives whatsoever or has a
negative impact give it six months now
of Republican control in the house and
give it a year and then we'll go out and
interview these very same people and say
what is the Republican house done it
will either be things they haven't done
things they did that are damaging or the
third one that you're going to see as
well they haven't been able to do
anything because of Democrats in the
Senate that's going to be the
explanation we're ready for it it's
unfortunately very depressing we have a
voicemail number that number is 219 to
David P you're welcome to call anytime
our anti-vaccine friend I guess uh Eric
from Mass called in and he really
assails my character in a horrible way
claiming that I'm happy that diamond
died take a listen
hey David it's Eric from math you must
excite time and the diamond and silk
died oh uh rooting for all your
political opponents to die from coven I
have never rooted for anyone to die of
covet
um Trump should be arrested just because
people have different thoughts than you
do I have never ever said Trump should
be arrested for any reason other than it
appears he committed crimes it's
unbelievable I mean I don't know where
you get off on this I'd like you to do
one thing do a video on
any crime that Trump committed
but you can't because you can't find one
so he didn't do anything
but you must be a happy day for you
buddy we have done extensive videos on
that we talk and again the the framing a
crime that Trump committed
people are innocent until proven guilty
so if I went on the air and said Trump
should be convicted of x-crime people
would rightly write to me and say well
but David you're innocent until they're
proven guilty he's got to be charged
then then you need a trial but of course
there is significant evidence that Trump
was criminally uh involved in the
incitement of the riots and that Trump's
actions trying to overturn the results
in Georgia even though Joe Biden won so
that those votes would be those
electoral votes would be given to Trump
was also an extortive fraud
um it is not up to me to determine that
though it is up for uh it is up to the
judicial system and we will hopefully
soon learn more about that we've got a
great bonus show for you today Katie
Porter is running for Senate I think
she's great we're going to talk about it
number two
John Bolton now says he will run in 2024
if it's what's necessary to prevent
Donald Trump from being president again
interesting guy that Bolton not a huge
fan of his I have to tell you and
Americans are piling up credit card debt
at record rates and it could prove very
costly to the economy as well as to
people's personal finances we will talk
about all of those stories and more on
today's bonus show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money yeah
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad in addition to that
tonight at 6 PM Eastern 3 P.M Pacific we
will have our first David Pacman show
Town Hall of 2023. I really want you to
be there we will be streaming it live on
YouTube twitch and Facebook we will also
be welcoming your calls you I'm it's
really you
at davidpackman.com Discord Discord is
how we take the calls I look forward to
speaking with you you can also just
watch even if you don't have a question
for me but it's going to be great and we
will see you then otherwise back here
tomorrow